Schwarze löcher bringen den tod wenn ein stern in die nähe eines schwarzen lochs gerät wird er
auseinander gerissen doch jetzt hat ein forschungsteam ein lang gehütetes geheimnis der schwarzen löcher gelüftet sie können unter bestimmten
voraussetzungen auch sterne zum leben erwecken ziemlich verrückt wenn man weiß wie schwarze löcher eigentlich alles aufsaugen und schon bald werden wir wahrscheinlich
so etwas auch beobachten können rott jetzt mal klick zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Vorab noch eine kleine bitte wir wollen kriegst du im jahr werbefrei machen bei einem video pro monat
haben wir und ihr es schon geschafft helft mit und werdet mitglied hier unter dem video draufklicken und uns mit einem kleinen betrag
unterstützen immer wenn genug zusammenkommen schalten wir vor einem monatlichen video mehr die werbung ab sind also jetzt schon zwölf videos pro jahr
zusammen gekommen und jetzt geht es endlich los
sie sind gleichzeitig die größten und die kleinsten objekte im weltall ihr zentrum also das gestirn ist vermutlich
unendlichkeit und der ereignishorizont also die grenze
nach deren überschreiten es weder für materie noch für licht eine wiederkehr gibt die ist
unfasslich riesig das größte was es im weltall gibt er vor kurzem hat ein amerikanisches astronomenteam
ein äußerst schwieriges loch entdeckt seit mehr als elf jahren frist ist die überreste eines sterns denen es einmal zerrissen hat das ganze
passiert in der galaxie ngc
5813 im sternbild der jungfrau der appetit von schwarzen löchern kann gigantisch sein ihr größtes talent
materie aufsaugen wenn es keine materie rund um ihr schwerefeld mehr gibt warten sie geduldig ab wie sie wieder zuschlagen
können und materie verschlingen danach stoßen sie einen strahl an partikeln aus dazu
juli komme ford von der university of colorado boulder die das ganze mit menschlichem verhalten
assoziiert schwarze löcher sind ganz schön stressig aber sie haben keine sehr guten tischmanieren
doch jetzt hat ein forschungsteam aus den usa anhand eines modells
herausgefunden dass schwarze löcher auch anders können der sie sind wohl auch in der lage neue sterne entstehen zu lassen
wo dafür müssen einige voraussetzungen gegeben seien bei dem stern muss es sich um einen
dessen zwerg handeln also eher ein kleiner stern der sich im letzten stadium
seines lebens befindet das schwarze loch selbst muss mittel schwer sein denn sonst würde es den weißen zwerg entweder komplett
ignorieren oder aber komplett
verschlingen nach angaben des forschungsteams läuft das ganze dann so ab kommt der weiße zwerg in die nähe des schwarzen loches
verdichtet er sich
gleichzeitig und dehnt sich aus dieser prozess wird in der fachsprache auch als teile des hradschin event bezeichnet
da sich der stern wie gesagt im endstadium befindet ist die kernfusion in ihm bereits zum stillstand gekommen also
erleuchtet gar nicht mehr so hell oder ist quasi gar kein stern mehr doch durch das
zusammenziehen was durch die kräfte des schwarzen loches
ausgelöst wird kann die kernfusion noch einmal aktiviert werden zwar nur für eine kurze zeit aber immerhin ein absolut
spektakuläres ereignis das alles konnte bisher nur in modellen beobachtet werden und das aus einem kuriosen grund
forschungsteams konnten in unserem universum nämlich bisher kein einziges schwarzes loch mit mittlerer größe aufspüren
stattdessen wurden immer nur entweder schwarze löcher mit einer masse von etwa 100 tonnen oder aber mit mehr als
100.000 tonnen aufgespürt doch theoretisch gesehen spricht spricht eigentlich nichts dagegen
dass es auch exemplare gibt die in der mitte liegen also eine masse von etwa 1000 bis 100000 tonnen aufweisen
möglicherweise könnten genau diese langersehnten schwarzen löcher durch das phänomen des teil des hradschin events
aufgespürt werden was ein
enormer fortschritt wäre so das forschungsteam in der pressemitteilung das problem derzeit gibt es noch keine instrumente die die bei diesem ereignis entstehen in
gravitationswellen messen können doch genau diese würden uns endlich auf die spur der
mittelschweren schwarzen löcher führen aber da sind wir ja mit der entwicklung relativ weit schon nach dem in nagoya hier auf der erde zum ersten
mal gravitationswellen gefunden wurden soll 2034
der europäische gravitationswellen direktor ins all geschickt werden statt ein paar kilometern größe wird dieses system
aus drei satelliten die
mehrere millionen millionen kilometer voneinander entfernt sind bestehen wow damit wird es auch mehrere
hunderttausend mal empfindlicher als lego sein und solche entdeckung werden dann endlich möglich ja hier geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken
existieren wir in einem schwarzen loch
ja und wenn ja kein video mehr zu diesem und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann folgt mir auch
nur da bekommt ihr von mir vor allen anderen
das neueste video ganz unabhängig von der abo box hier auf youtube die ja bei dem ein oder andere nicht so ganz wird perfekt
funktioniert ja und dafür da drauf klicken und gerne auch ein abo da lassen und natürlich nicht die
genau die glocke vergessen bis dahin
bleibt dran